the people of the city are showing an
amazing amount of strength and
resilience they're reaching out to help
families that lost loved ones in the
bombing Jonathan Vigliotti is in
Manchester's Albert Square this morning
where thousands of people attended a
vigil for the victims yesterday Jonathan
good morning Scott on that memorial
continuing to grow here one of many
throughout the city of the 22 people
confirmed dead police say there are
still a number that have not been
identified
which means this morning there are
parents anxiously awaiting word this is
my daughter Olivia I haven't seen her
since five o'clock last night she was a
mother's plea for help only grew more
desperate as her daughter's absence
continued I just need my dog home I need
to know where she is
everybody should have to do this even if
you think is her just let someone know
that it might be her please just follow
I want to back in my eyes
but today Charlotte Campbell returned to
Facebook her hope lost r.i.p my darling
precious gorgeous girl Olivia Campbell
she wrote taken far far too soon go sing
with the angels and keep smiling mummy
loves you so much
fifteen-year-old Olivia was among the
thousands leaving the ariana grande show
when terror struck concert goer Alicia
Hattersley
managed to escape in the chaos just goes
back into my mind again just hear the
screams and see the people running you
look people like shine whereas my memory
like a cult family I just think I
shouldn't don't want help but didn't
know what to do
last night as the scale of this tragedy
continued to take shape thousands
gathered together at a vigil to remember
those lost and to stand defiant against
an attack on innocence many of the
victims who did not make it out or
teenage girls the youngest victim just
eight years old don't think it's really
sunk in shocked and it's very close to
home I've come here today to show my
support because Manchester stand
together and we stand strong and
nothing's gonna stop that ever and some
of those who did make it out found
safety and comfort in the hands of
strangers we spoke with one taxi driver
yesterday who was in that exact location
at the time of the attack he said he saw
hundreds of people running to him he
opened up his door and crammed eight
people into his van Scot he continued to
do those trips throughout the night
Jonathan Vigliotti and Manchester's
Alberts where Jonathan thanks we're
going to have much more from Manchester
ahead including the reactions of many
people that we spoke to during last
night's vigil for now back to all of you
at the broadcast Center in New York
Thank You Scott in Manchester